je voudrais maintenant m'adresser à toi
toi que je vois depuis le début toi qui
l'as au premier rang qui me regardent
qui me dévisage qui m'écoutent me désire
me jalousent aussi et je te comprends
oui oui oui je parle de toi scarlett
wahou scarlett alors je sais bien qu aux
états unis on t'appelle scarlett
mais ici en france ton prénom c'est waou
scarlett
parce que quand j'ai dit aux gens que tu
venais tout le monde a dit waouh
scarlett
mais on t'appelle aussi scarlett non tu
dit cole ou alors mon dieu scarlets et
puis il ya aussi aux scarlett elle est
trop bas enfin bref t'as plein de
prénoms ici mais euh moi moi je sais pas
comment ma paie l'eau aux états unis
mais ici en france c'est plutôt c'est
s'il vient ici où cécile passe moi ça
enfin voila je suis tellement fier est
tellement honorée de te compter parmi
nous que ce soir pour te célébrer
j'appelle monsieur quentin tarantino
enfin world quentin tarantino
quoique
pour ceux qui foncent du cinéma il
existe tout se ferait toutes sortes
d'honneur possible mais aucun honneur
net aussi près celui décerné en france
car la france est le pays et le peuple
le plus cinéphile du monde et les
français vous rendre thomas jeu malgré
votre très jeune âge ils rendent hommage
à votre belle carrière et à la
profondeur de vos internationaux
enfin et à titre personnel j'aurais
vraiment voulu ça se voter pour vous aux
oscars pour votre prestation
bouleversante bayonne sur le film de
spike jones comme ce plaisir mais j'ai
refusé j'ai doublement plaisir à vous
remettre ce c'est ici en france p
licitation stade
merci d'avoir pris le temps de nous
sauver de la médiocrité
merci un immense merci quelqu'un je
voudrais vous remercier pour votre
travail mais faire que nous cherchons
tous être meilleur je suis très
reconnaissante
d'ailleurs je cherche du travail
actuellement je voudrais dire que
recevoir cet honneur ce soir et un
conteneur je voudrais remercier tout
d'abord la france et la ville de cuari
de baby war accueilli si chaleureuse qui
me passe
je ne suis pas touché de la très grande
beauté de cette ville et de la technique
et ses habitants j'ai toujours senti
quelque part que la france accueillait
comme chez moi il y avait des projets
peut-être trop complexes ou trop
controversé et bien ils ont trouvé leur
place dans la liste gris
cinématographique française qui sait
reconnaître ceux qui prennent des
risques créatifs c'est une qualité qu'il
ne faut pas perdre
comme c'est bien souvent le regard
ailleurs à l'industrie cinématographique
française de m'avoir donné ce refuge
culturel
comme ça a été le cas pour bientôt
c'est fou de penser que ça fait plus de
vingt ans que je suis une enfant de ce
milieu du cinéma et pourtant je me sens
milieu de ma carrière et j'ai le
sentiment de commencer enfin à
comprendre mon travail est au bout de
deux ans à temps et plus j'aime mon
métier plus que jamais
c'est vraiment un très grand bonheur en
mode je me sens humble devant ces
grandes personnalités du monde du cinéma
et maintenant eh bien il faut que je
m'assure que je mérite bien ce ch vous
remercier alain terzian et de l'académie
aux mains merci l europe 1 il est une
inspiration de tous les jours qui m'a
appris à apprécier la france la culture
française dans tout ce qu'elle a de
délicieux à ma famille à new york
merci de leur amour leur soutien merci à
mes collègues
là-bas tout là-bas à hollywood qui
m'aiment et qui me soutient ici et puis
enfin je voudrais dédier ce césar à ma
grand-mère dort aussi cela la première
francophone de notre famille ou un sens
elle est à moitié celle que je suis est
appréciée celle que je peux
merci